[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so you have a
lot of questions for me I'm going to get
straight into them and hopefully you
will learn some really interesting and
fun facts about me how often do I work
out well I try to work out at least
between four to five times weekly most
of the time I get to do at least four
workouts per week so I like to aim for
at least two strength training sessions
and one hit session and also one more
gentle and easy workout such as going
for a hike outdoors or just running
outdoors so it's a mixture of high
intensity strength training and also
something fun outdoors how many pets do
I have those of you who have been
following me on Instagram you will
definitely notice rusty so that's my
baby boy I got him about three and a
half years ago and then I have a cat
called Marty
we got him one year after rusty and also
one year ago we got another female dog
called Nala so I have three pets two
dogs and also one cat and they get along
really well what makes me happy
gosh what makes me happy right now I
would say that just being able to spend
time with my family members and also my
loved ones because having a really busy
schedule
it is always so difficult to be able to
find that time to just spend it with my
family especially because my parents
they don't live in the same town as I do
they're about six to eight hours away
driving or one hour by flight so
whenever they come down to visit me
those weekends will be my happiest
weekend I would say so it's really about
having quality time with my loved ones
what's your biggest fear my biggest fear
would definitely be feeling stagnant and
not improving that's always my biggest
fear whenever I feel that I'm stuck in
the same situation or doing the same
things and not progressing and not doing
anything different that's always my
biggest fear because I feel like I'm not
growing I'm not advancing I'm not
learning something new so for me it is
very important that I'm always aware of
what I'm doing where I am right now and
how can I keep pushing and how can I
keep progressing and growing whether
it's in my own personal life my career
or even my relationship with my friends
and also the loved ones so whenever I
feel stagnant that's when it will really
hit me and I know that do you know what
Joanna you got to do something you got
to challenge yourself go out there and
do something that you're fearful off so
one thing I always tell myself do one
thing that you're fearful of every
single day what is your biggest fear do
that what's the most important thing you
have learned throughout your journey of
being on YouTube so when I first started
obviously I didn't just it was very
scary for me to post my first video
knowing that it's not my best video
first of all it was very awkward and I
had to pretend as though I'm working out
to an imaginary audience and pretty much
it's just a camera like right now I'm
talking to you so when I first started I
told myself you know I join our two
things take yourself less seriously
don't take yourself too seriously
because I'm a perfectionist so I always
take my stuff really seriously and
everything I do I want it to be perfect
and sometimes if it's not perfect I'd
rather not do it so one thing I've
taught myself is take yourself less
seriously just put yourself out there
and see what happens when you start to
take yourself less seriously you're more
bold you're more adventurous and you
tend to do more things and by doing more
things you never know what you can
achieve so that's one thing I told
myself tickets yourself less seriously
and you know don't really care what
others think about you but care more
about what you think about yourself and
how you can continue to learn from every
every mistakes
I wouldn't say mistakes but every
practice so the more I upload videos the
more I film the better I become at it
and also the second thing is be
shameless what I mean by that is if you
want something you've got to go out
there and get it some people come up to
me si gosh you're so lucky you
your dream job I always tell them I
didn't find my dream job this job did
not exist 10 years ago or I didn't tell
myself in high school or in college that
you know what one day I'm gonna stop
filming videos online because that did
not exist back then so what I'm trying
to say is you've got to create your own
dream job you've got to create your own
goals be shameless if you want something
go out there do it
ask someone keep doing it keep trying
until you get it and even after you get
it keep on pushing and keep on improving
so you can't just sit down and expect
opportunities and and people to come to
you you've got to go out there create
your own opportunities that's what I'm
trying to say so whatever you want go
out there be shameless and do it how do
you spend your money so haha well that's
a very good question I would say that I
am actually quite a minimalistic person
so I don't own a lot of things I do own
things that I find to be useful if I
need something that I would get it the
thing is because I've actually moved 12
times in 11 years since I left home I've
moved 12 times and every time I move I
have to sort of like declutter and get
rid of things that I don't need and the
more I move the more I realized that I
don't need a lot of material things I
only need things that would help me with
myself obviously and also pretty much
just basic things so when it comes to
even shopping and all that I'm not a big
shopping person as such so I prefer to
spend my money on experiences so I love
traveling I would choose to spend my
money travel and see the world and
basically buy experiences because those
are moments which you will remember and
cherish for life so for instance last
year I've travelled to I would say at
least eight different countries and I
like to even travel with my family take
them on a holiday for me those are
really valuable moments so I would
definitely say I would choose to buy
experiences over material things do you
have a boyfriend
well million-dollar question eh what do
you think okay right fine let's get into
it so currently I don't have a boyfriend
my last relationship was actually three
and a half years ago after I left the UK
pretty much it's not that I don't want
to have a boyfriend it's not that I'm
also actively searching but I would say
I'm still waiting or yeah who knows I'm
still waiting for the right person what
is the right person a so for me it's
someone that I can really connect with
on a deeper level someone that I can
have a conversation with someone who is
spiritual someone who has a electrically
a sexy mind so someone that's not just
thinking but about himself but someone
that really cares about others as well
someone that wants to help other people
that's really important to me and also
someone that can be my calming force
because I can get really sometimes I can
get really you know like all over the
place so I need someone that can solve
like calm me down and put me back you
know like centered me basically yeah so
hopefully I'll let you know what's one
thing that people find attractive about
you so whenever I ask someone what is it
about me that is different from other
people a lot of the times I'll get the
same answer that when whenever someone
look at me whenever they talk to me they
feel and they know that I'm a very
strong person I would agree to a certain
extent I am a strong person I am very
strong in my opinions I am very strong
in the way I do things I am very strong
in my mind and when I want something
when I know something is right I will
push and you know really make it come
true but at the same time I'm also very
vulnerable basically and people don't
see that about me unless yeah people
don't see that about me but for me it's
not a weakness I believe that you can be
strong and you can also be vulnerable at
the same time because no matter how
strong you are you would definitely have
your down times your down times will be
when you know sometimes I just feel like
you know what I don't want to I just
don't want to get up sometimes it I just
don't want to get up and do what I'm
doing right now
and I questioned myself why why are you
doing this Johanna why are you you know
filming all these videos and continue to
create content you know you're you're
trying to create a network do people
really care about it and all that then I
ask myself why did you even bother
getting started and whenever I ask
myself that question it's always because
I want to be able to reach out to you so
if my video is helping just one person
out there whether it's to make them live
a happier life to live a healthier life
it better and impacting your surrounding
then I'll continue to film my videos so
you got to find your anchor point in
your life what is one thing that keeps
you centered and what is one thing that
will continue to drive you to do what
you want to do so basically what is your
purpose in life even if you don't know
what to purpose in life because I didn't
under what's my purpose in life before
that but what is your passion go towards
your passion keep pushing on that and
eventually you will find your purpose
what's on my bucket list I want to see
Narwhal in our wall is that how you
pronounce it basically it's the sea
unicorn yeah that would be a dream come
true really yeah it's a sea unicorn okay
it's not big it's not some fantasy it
exists and you can pretty much see it I
know in Canada or Iceland so hopefully
one day I'll be able to travel there and
go on an expedition to see Narwhal and
also a polar bears that will be my
ultimate Travel bucket list what has
been the highlight of my year while
20-17 has been incredible so many things
has happened I've been on my first cover
but I would say my ultimate highlight
has to be hitting the 1 million mark
because I've been on YouTube for five
years now five years and being able to
achieve that is it's not just an
accomplishment for myself but it's also
an accomplishment to you all of you
without anyone of you this would not be
possible and also I would say that my
biggest the biggest thing I'm grateful
for is also my production team the guy
behind the camera
you can't see him right now the lady
behind that you can't see them right now
but after doing use my youtube channel
for four years last year from April
onwards I finally got my own production
team and they have been really really
really helpful and they've been a huge
blessing so right now I have people to
help me out with filming editing it's
such a huge burden in a weight lifted
off because then I can produce a lot
more content and I can I have the space
to be more creative as well so yeah
that's what I I'm really grateful for
why did I move back to Malaysia if you
have been following my channel for more
than four years you'll notice that I
started when I was in the UK and then I
moved back to Malaysia three years ago
so I was living in the UK for four years
Cardiff and also London and then three
years ago I decided that I'm gonna move
back to Malaysia first of all I felt
that with online I can pretty much film
and do my videos anywhere in the world
but at the same time I mean I don't know
whether you've experienced this before
but living away from your family members
when you only get to see them once a
year and you realize that gosh my
parents are aging and where have I been
all these years that really hits me real
hard when I was there when I saw I
remember seeing my dad about you know
like five years ago and he's like yeah
daddy's too healthy and all that and
then I remember when I visited him I'm
like gosh has he really aged and that
read that hit me quite hard and I told
myself do I want to continue to stay
there or do I want to be able to spend
more time with my family I would say
that's the main reason of me moving back
because I felt that I wasn't being able
to spend more time with my family and
that my parents are just living their
life and somehow they're aging and I I
mean I'm not there and also another
reason is I felt that the fitness
industry in Malaysia it is still very
young it is still growing and I felt
that there will be more opportunities
for me here
to begin with when I first moved moved
back I was still questioning myself at
that time did I make the right decision
am I going to regret it but looking back
now I have not regretted my decision at
all
now at least I get to see my parents
once a month and definitely I have been
given so much more opportunities here
including setting up my own studio and
having my own production team what's
your biggest advice to someone who wants
to stop okay sorry sorry
like I'll sleep okay this is what
happened these people don't see that but
lack of sleep I've been sleeping I don't
want to say about five hours setting up
this whole studio took me one month and
but it's all good it's all good I'm not
complaining it's been a blessing right
let's move on what's your biggest advice
to new youtubers basically so new
youtubers first of all don't start a
channel just for the sake of starting a
channel don't start a channel just
because you want to be a youtuber don't
do that it's not going to last you very
long so start a channel and know what is
it that you really want to share with
your audience on your channel that's the
first thing okay and remember that when
you first start a channel don't expect
your channel to just boom and whoa
100,000 subscribers or 1 million it
doesn't work that way
expect 10 views expect my 10 subscribers
to begin with but that's okay because
that's how we get started everybody has
to start somewhere and don't stop there
don't give up so if you ask me three
things that we all should strive to have
is first of all consistency be
consistent with your content be
consistent with your upload schedule and
be consistent with the type of content
that you want to put out there tell
yourself I'm gonna upload at least once
a week so then when your audience or
your followers come back to your channel
they will know when to expect your video
okay and secondly know your value why
are you doing what you're doing
what kind of content that you want to
put out there and
what is it that you're offering to your
audience and the final part is
discipline discipline discipline
discipline I mean whether it's starting
a YouTube channel whether it's basically
whether it's working out whether it's in
your career everything really revolves
around disciplining motivation only
brings you that far but discipline will
bring it to another level so this leads
on to my next point really a lot of you
ask me how do you stay motivated when it
comes to working out I'm not always
motivated especially when I'm really
tired I'm not motivated to work out all
the time but when you have disciplined
when you have instill that discipline
you will make yourself go to the gym or
do something active because then you
know that it will you will gain the
reward afterwards so even if you don't
feel motivated
well hack when you when you tell
yourself you know what I don't feel
motivated that's when you should be
hitting the gym or you should be doing
something that you don't want to do
where do I see myself in five years time
sitting on this chair feeling five years
older and still doing this maybe with a
baby in my arm I'm just kidding
I don't know where do I see myself in
five years time definitely still sharing
online content but I definitely see it
on a bigger scale so that is why I
started her Network last year it's
because I don't just want to do this on
my own anymore I want to be able to
share my platform with other female
creators out there when it comes to
fitness I only know that much when but
when you're able to collaborate with
other like-minded people and when you're
able to collaborate with other people
who has you know different sets of
knowledge together you're able to share
so much more and I hope that you all
will continue to support her network I
know that some people find that you know
what I don't want any of this content
I just want Joanna's content let's be
open let's just stay open and I really
believe that all these contents will
offer you a lot more what's one thing
you wish you could do better
the more success you have it comes with
more responsibilities as well and with
more responsibilities
I'm always stressing myself out I'm
always pressurizing myself because I
feel that to a certain extent I'm not as
connected with you guys and that's what
I really feel before that when my
channel was a lot smaller when I have
less followers I could reply to each and
every one of you but now it is just
impossible so sometimes when I read the
comments sometimes when I scroll through
the comments I really want to reply to
all of you because I know that your
questions are really important to you
and you're really seeking help but at
the same time I just physically and
mentally and not able to answer to all
your questions so that's one thing I
really wish I could do better
hence that's the reason why I want to do
more of this type of videos to be able
to answer your questions and hopefully
help you through your fitness journey as
well but I hope you that I hope that you
guys will understand this and and yeah
that's one thing I really wish I could
do better and sometimes I do feel deep
down I really feel guilty about it right
guys I really hope you have enjoyed this
video I hope that you've got to know me
better on a personal level let me know
what other questions you have in the
comments below and do you know what
let's just do this more often let me
know what other questions you have and
hopefully I'll be able to stream live as
well in the future and do check out my
youtube channel subscribe if you haven't
yet done it I will be having a lot more
workout videos recipes and also fitness
tips coming your way and all the best